m
[Musique]
des concerts gratuits donnés en public
par des élèves ou des professeurs c'est
l'un des volets de l'académie
internationale de musique d'orléans
l'événement est piloté par la pianiste
coréenne rosa park
elle a entraîné avec elle à orléans une
cinquantaine de jeunes musiciens coréen
avec une quinzaine d'élèves français et
suisses pendant une semaine les cours
dispensés par seize professeurs de piano
de flûte alto ou encore de violoncelle
rosa park fait une démarche absolument
extraordinaire sur le plan du désir
qu'elle à elle de mettre ces jeunes dans
une autre situation pour recevoir autre
chose dans un autre pays avec tout ce
que cela suppose de 2 dans le sens pour
eux
s'enrichir échanger apprendre ce sont
les maîtres mots de cette rencontre
musicale qui a pour cadre le vénérable
conservatoire de musique d'orléans à sa
façon lui aussi participent à cette
immersion dans la culture musicale
française
on courait de l'été les élèves et
travaille juste et pro technique
je pense mais en france on peut chercher
beaucoup de choses par exemple de
culture
aussi on peut penser beaucoup de choses
pour la musique pour peut donner c'est
une ouverture sur la littérature sur la
poésie surtout ce qu'on trouve en france
et comme en allemagne d'ailleurs en
europe notre vieille europe voilà qui a
été comme un nourrissez chose a souvent
les racines
les cours de l'académie de musique 2018
vont se poursuivre jusqu'à samedi les
concerts gratuits aussi c'est tous les
soirs à 20h salle de l'institut
[Musique]